una nueva experiencia en caracas la
noticia sobre la apertura de una
supuesta tienda de starbucks en
venezuela generó alegría entre los
ciudadanos en medio de la crisis
económica que atraviesa el país
esta opción que nunca teníamos acá en
nuestro país vine porque quería probar
algo nuevo
pero rápidamente se convirtió en una
gran controversia
la razón no se trata de starbucks aunque
el local omite el nombre de la compañía
el logotipo y los envases son idénticos
en su eslogan se lee la frase uy
brownlee ser un programa de starbucks
que permite a terceros comprar granos de
café directamente de la empresa y
elaborar sus propios productos pero la
misma compañía descartó que este
programa exista en venezuela el local se
encuentra ubicado en el supermercado y
una tienda enfocada en comercio
electrónico y las acusaciones de
piratería surgieron inmediatamente el
responsable de hit tuvo que aclarar que
no son starbucks que todo se trata de un
malentendido y que sólo busca que los
clientes tengan una experiencia
divertida aunque no mencionó porque hace
uso de la famosa sirena de dos colas
para ferias de nosotros lo que hicimos
fue adquirir los equipos
obviamente y el producto y y aquí en
adquirimos los equipos nos dio un guy
line de que podíamos hacer que no
podíamos hacer y ese ghailan lo estamos
cumpliendo a nosotros a cabalidad la
controversia llega en un país con un
largo historial de productos de
imitación antes de alimentos uno de los
casos más sonados es el de los famosos
cereales de la marca que los cuya plata
fue expropiada por el gobierno en 2018
después de que cesara operaciones por el
deterioro de la situación económica